you go in a pool with water shoes
not the pool no pool water shoes pool
though yeah my dad told me last week he
can't he's happy they can finally go in
the pool at his housing complex in Tampa
because he just got his water shoes
yeah that's is that a problem if you
know what though I'm thinking about your
dad now your dad served time yeah this
might be a prison thing it might be a
prison it was dirty and shower because
everybody who's in the prisons were
probably disgusting right that's the
last time I was in the hospital that's
why I was in there what happened I had
foot you had foot yeah dude
that that and that's dangerous yeah
really yeah you know it would have
prevented that right water shoes
[Laughter]